[Musica]
prendetevi il momento per pensare a
qualcosa che vorreste cambiare della
vostra vita
potrebbe essere qualcosa di piccolo ho
anche un cambiamento radicale oppure
anche solo la sensazione di voler
cambiare qualcosa
ma ancora non riuscita a identificare
bene che cosa
vorrei che tenere a mente questo
pensiero mentre parlo fino alla fine
che cosa significa
rinascita
nascere nuovamente
ma è fisicamente possibile
cosa può quindi rinascere
cresciamo nasciamo sappiamo che la vita
è una
e la vita è una e vero
tendenzialmente
95 anni ai più longevi ne avrò anche
cento e oltre però insomma arrivare
incartapecoriti massimo quindi 95 anni
sembra giusto di cui i primi cinque
ripassiamo nell'incoscienza
e diciamo c'era tutto anche gli ultimi
cinque quindi 85 anni per vivere questo
unica vita
ma questa unica vita in quanti modi può
essere vissuta in 85 anni
dieci anni fa all'età di 19 anni
mi sono ammalata di anoressia
vivevo a braccetto con il mio disturbo
alimentare ogni singolo giorno dalla
mattina alla sera lo bramavo il cibo lo
desideravo lo sognavo lo odiavo per me
la vita reali
per me era inconcepibile
pensare di poterne uscire a pensare che
potesse esistere una vita al di fuori di
quello
e a diversi estremi
un po così un po per tantino
siamo talmente incanalati nelle nostre
vite nelle nostre abitudini le nostre
routine che come se ci fossimo messi
parrocchie ormai abbiamo intrapreso
quella strada quella e va avanti che si
sveglia la mattina lavori a riesci dopo
il lavoro fai sport e c con gli amici la
sera e poi ricomincia tutto di nuovo
tutta capo e quasi non ci poniamo
nemmeno più la domanda ma io potrei fare
qualcos'altro
e se ti dicessi che puoi cambiare
che oggi puoi compiere una scelta
che ha il potenziale di completamente
stravolgere la tua vita che domani la
tua vita potrebbe essere completamente
diversa grazie alla scelta di oggi
è funzionato un po così per me ero nel
pieno del mio disturbo alimentare però
un giorno ancora dire cacchio però
esisteva un'altra silvia c'era un prima
c'era la silvia di prima
e allora ho capito che quella mia
situazione di quel momento era la
conseguenza
di una serie di scelte
negative
e che quindi
potevo ribaltare la situazione
compiendo una serie
scelte
possibilmente positiva quindi
l'idea di poter cambiare
anche solo l'idea di poter cambiare è
stato ciò che mi ha salvato la vita
perché è stato grazie a quell idea
che io poi ho intrapreso il mio percorso
di rinascita
però
puoi cambiare no puoi cambiare
quel lavoro che non ti soddisfa puoi
cambiare quell'amicizia che non stimola
o quella relazione che ti blocca io ho
cambiato ho cambiato città tantissime
cambiato case altrettanto tantissime
vita
ma soprattutto
ho cambiato idea
una delle cose più difficili da
concepire e anche accettare da concepire
perché
cresciamo e ci sentiamo sempre dire un
pil a tua scelta
e nel momento in cui l'hai fatto
se in quella non puoi cambiare perché
nel momento in cui osi dire io vorrei
cambiare di risulta incoerente
ma che cos'è l'incoerenza
non cambiare percorso di studi dopo che
hai fatto qualche esame capisci che non
è la tua strada che non ti piace
studiare fisica astronomica
oppure non cambiare stile di vita perché
ormai è scelto quello o non cambiare
gusti passioni interessi oppure è più
incoerente vivere infelici
vivere con la consapevolezza di aver
potuto cambiare
ma di non averlo fatto
per paura di disturbare il giudizio
altrui
e forse questo è il significato di
rinascita
capire che cosa ci fa stare bene e agire
di conseguenza
alcuni potrebbero chiamarlo anche
egoismo
però se io sto bene con me stessa io
sono una persona felice
allegra e sprigiona gioia
e nel mio piccolo
quella gioia può essere contagiante e
può contagiare chi mi circonda creando
un effetto domino
che può portare un sorriso dalla mia
bocca a quella degli altri è egoismo
questo
ma se io cambio e poi non va come deve
andare
risulta in un fallimento
vi racconto una storia
io ho studiato per cinque anni
all'università
e
quando mi sono laureata dopo un anno ho
intrapreso il lavoro che avevo tanto
idealizzato tanto voluto durante i
cinque anni di studio dopo cinque anni
facevo il lavoro che avevo sognato
dopo due settimane volevo scappare
alla fine sono durata nove mesi
è stato veramente un parto
è stato un fallimento
in quei nove mesi ho preso tante cose
nel mondo del lavoro che ancora ad oggi
mi porto dietro ma soprattutto ho
appreso tante cose su me stessa
ho capito cosa mi faceva stare bene e
cosa non piaceva cosa mi piaceva stare
male
il fallimento è un fallimento
solo nel momento in cui non gli
permettiamo
di insegnarci qualcosa
io non mi sento arrivata nella vita
penso che la terra mi tremerà sotto i
piedi
altre centinaia di volte
ma io so
che potrò trovare la forza in qualche
modo per rinascere
perché io so che
posso cambiare
che non importa
se
questo porta un disturbo nel giudizio
degli altri
non importa se risulta incoerente ai
loro occhi e soprattutto
che niente sarà mai un fallimento
se io non glielo permetto di diventarlo
quindi vi chiedo di ripensare a quella
cosa
che vi eravate figurati all'inizio
quando incominciato a parlare
e vi chiedo
siete pronti a rinascere
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]